I'm not a big
um believer again in that disinformation
campaign but others believe that that's
what this was to create a public hype
that that that reached every corner of
the globe which it did I mean we can't
argue that
create that hype then shoot it down
both figuratively and literally but look
at the conversation since these balloons
got got shot down this to me may come
off as conspiratorial uh but I'm gonna
throw it out there anyway you know you
have that Chinese spy balloon and we
shot it down then in the course of like
days we started shooting stuff down you
know all over the place then nothing
right nothing is essentially happened
since then but what did they do they
connected UAP and the conversation to
these balloons
that happened in the mainstream media
then all of a sudden I'm seeing it on
Twitter and I don't want to name names
but they are bigger journalists who had
uh reporting for periodicals you'd
recognize and again I just don't want to
be rude here on on journalists but
you'll see a shift that they were I
don't want to say Pro UAP but very much
reporting legitimately on the UAP topic
a year and a half ago two years ago and
now they're making fun of it
and the reason is is because that
message of well it's all balloons it's
all foreign spy Tech we screwed up they
got balloons over us uh but that's what
we're talking about with UAP so move
along here and some of those journalists
have bought it hook line and sinker and
so now their articles have changed their
scope has changed even the Masthead has
changed their tone of reporting on UAP
it's an interesting connection that the
documents that got those three original
UAP videos out the official document
describe them as balloons and drones why
all a coincidence maybe I don't know but
for me that's where I start questioning
and going that's too much of a
coincidence to me because that was an
alarm to me in 2018. and those
contradictions never went away now here
we are in 2023 literally connecting
balloons to UAP I do not believe that
that is the source of the true UAP
discussion that we should be having so
let me stress that to you I do not
believe this is about balloons and
drones fully partially it is yes
absolutely it's partially conversation
but not fully and I think at this point
that shift is starting to happen
recently there was a UAP hearing and Dr
Sean Kirkpatrick who who heads the the
UAP office they were talking about
drones they were talking about balloons
spy platforms and even though he said I
I I'm paraphrasing but essentially he
couldn't attribute some of the
Unexplained cases to Russia or to China
specifically that he found indicators of
it now obviously those indicators were
likely set in a classified setting
because he didn't elaborate past that
and the two Sen Senators that were
actually there that showed up I think
there were three uh ultimately but one
just popped in for one question and left
uh no one pushed him on it so it's
either from the classified session or
whatever so you can see that the
Pentagon is now trying to kind of shift
that discussion I think that's the wrong
thing but it makes you wonder about the
allegations against a disinformation
campaign uh was this part of the plan
now as conspiratorial as that sounds I
will add this
backtrack all the way to the 1960s even
to 1952 if you wanted
and their aim during the Project Blue
Book era the CIA realized that they
needed to squash public interest in this
in in UFOs in the the UFO world that was
into 1953 with what they call the
Robertson panel right all of the
documentation's out so this isn't crazy
talk uh all of this is backed by
official documents they needed to
explain not investigate but explain
because they felt that the general
public was the national security threat
that we with our interest with our voice
and with our ability could essentially
overload uh the capabilities at the time
of the US government and the military
and start flooding 9-1-1 and so on and
so forth so it became less about
investigation more about explanation
and then when you get into the 1960s the
same thing happened very similar to
today you had whistleblowers that came
out from the military you had people
that uh were essentially the debunkers
well they brought together a panel of
scientists uh that ultimately led to
what they call the Condon committee
study and they shut UFOs down in 1969
and officially closed it in January of
1970. what's the Condon committee sorry
yeah so that was that was essentially a
culmination of scientists that were
going to analyze the data that had been
collected from 1947 I believe it was
1966 or so when they started looking at
it or at least talking about it but the
data all the way through that date and
they were going to analyze the the
findings of the Air Force and issue
their their conclusion per se it was
this a worthwhile phenomena to to study
and ultimately that scientific study
determined no and so the government said
we're not interested either and shut it
all down because they felt that it
wasn't a threat to National Security and
what uh objects they did collect and
investigate uh were largely all
identified and those that were not uh
were simply because of lack of facts and
and lack of data eerily similar to what
Dr Kirkpatrick just said to Congress the
majority of them and he said majority
um and there's a put a pin in that for
for a second but he said majority were
clutter identify identifiable objects
and whatever other
that sounds believable because I imagine
that the majority of what's unidentified
is usually explainable yeah and and he
did say majority right so so again where
I said put a pin in that he later said
about half were remaining unidentified
okay so that's not a majority but my
whole point is actually opposite of what
you might have thought I was going to
say I'm surprised that it wasn't 98 of
clutter misidentifications and
identifiable objects honestly because I
think that the human eye thinks they see
things and given the proper scrutiny
yeah you're talking about the high 90s
easy so the fact that it was a roughly
half
um that's amazing to me when you're
talking about
650 cases so as of of mid or so April of
2023 he said in that hearing 650 cases
roughly half you know essentially
weren't uh identified so are we on the
same path to what we were are these
contradictions relevant I say yes
especially for the history of this but I
say yes and is there disinformation
coming from all angles you just watched
a clip from the theories of everything
channel for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy